one of the leading lights of modern
feminism you will surely go down in the
annals of history just as surely as Lisa
Lampanelli will go down in the locker
room of the Houston Rockets hey Bo jack
are you a Zoe or a Zelda don't know what
that means well I was talking to Wayne
who's Wayne I'm Wayne
Wayne's writing an article about me for
BuzzFeed fun fact Wayne is also my
ex-boyfriend ha funny pretty cool a bow
Jack Diane's writing a book about you
Wayne's renting an article about me
we're the same how could you think that
that's the same my book will be in
libraries for hundreds of years
your BuzzFeed article will be crammed
between an animated gif of a cat falling
asleep and a list of fun facts about
Legally Blonde ah classic Zooey I still
don't know what that means well are you
familiar with mr. peanut butters house
do you mean his sitcom that
coincidentally had the exact same
premise as my sitcom not the exact same
mr. peanut butters house featured a pair
of twins Zoey and Zelda Zelda was the
sunny fun loved and extrovert look at my
punkin mr. peanut butter pretty smiles
Ellie belly
whereas Zoey was the smart cynical
introvert my pumpkins throwing up
because Halloween encourages excessive
consumption of refined sugar at a time
when obesity rates are sky high plus
Halloween costumes are a gateway to
casual racism why don't I keep the knife
so Bo
now was the show's acting ham-fisted in
the writing moronic no yes
but the Zoe Zelda paradigm rang true I
believe everyone's either a Zoe or Zelda
for example Nixon was Zoe in Kennedy a
Zelda it's r2d2 and c3po Zoe and emily
deschanel so Zoe's a Zoe no Zoe's a
Zelda Emily's the Zoe what a crazy world
so which one are you bow Jack I think
I'm above this said the Zoe
[Music]